getting into her coved protective gear
takes some time
and more than a little courage but nurse
desanti is just glad to have equipment
available
right after graduating from nursing
school last year she was sent to the
front line of the pandemic in jakarta
and became infected herself a few months
after she recovered
the second wave hit the country
we even had to rotate the oxygen bottles
for patients in the emergency room
and they kept coming and coming even
after we were out of beds and oxygen
those who came had low oxygen levels i
was overwhelmed
the intensive care unit at this hospital
is still at full capacity
even though case numbers in the capital
have been decreasing
officially covid has claimed more than a
hundred thousand lives in indonesia
with many health workers among the
victims
they've mostly been given the chinese
cinevac vaccine
now medical staff like dr puspita are
getting a booster shot of moderna
to better protect them
i'm really tired this is just me but
when there are a lot of cases
i start talking to myself this is insane
i have to work with covet 19 cases over
and over
i often feel like crying but then i
realize i'm not alone
my colleagues are also working hard
doctors and nurses fully support the
strict lockdown measures that the
indonesian government has enforced to
flatten the curve
in jakarta roads have even been blocked
to reduce mobility
only those with the proper papers like
health workers
are allowed to pass
for weeks jakarta's big shopping malls
remain closed
except for supermarkets the malls will
reopen in late august
but only to people with vaccination
certificates
a trial program has already started
according to data from jakarta state
hospitals the mortality rate during this
second wave has been almost
four times higher for the unvaccinated
than for those with two
shots
please get the vaccine while you can get
free access
whatever vaccine it is take it because
it helps
us fight the virus please obey health
protocols and put your mask on
there are still many people out there
who do not wear their mask correctly
are very proud of their daughter they
belong to the eighteen percent of the
population
who've had one dose of the vaccine only
eight percent are fully vaccinated
and while the rate of infections may be
falling in jakarta
the delta variant is now threatening
indonesia's poorly equipped regions
and checking in on some other pandemic
developments in the region
china has either fired or disciplined
more than 30 local officials
for their response to its latest covet
outbreak dozens of cities are reporting
cases
of the delta variant south korea
is opening vaccination reservations to
all adults over 18.
the country is seeing a surge in cases
among the young and
unvaccinated and malaysia is relaxing
covert restrictions for the fully
vaccinated
but only in states with reduced case
numbers and higher vaccination rates
you